haha the Joe Rogan experience when we
were doing that project trying to get
you know guys from to stop drinking out
in Siberia we had like a little hunting
cabin we were based at and I woke up one
morning and we had a stupid dog that
just barked at everything and I just
hear the blog on red squirrel psych got
up and I didn't get up I let it bark and
then my buddy got up like an hour later
and went out to brush his teeth and came
running back in fact there's a bear out
there so I went up jumped up looked out
and a bear had killed a moose like less
than a hundred we could have watched the
whole thing if I would have just woke up
right away but it came kill the moose
right next to our cabin when we came out
it's sauce and took off running and
we're like oh man so we walked over
there like she's a whole warm moose
still here so we like cut it up Holly
back dark stole it from the back dollar
from the bear bear come back oh yeah
like three days later like we were in in
their shelter and sure enough that one
dog just came running in and hide hid
under the bed out there barking it's a
we grabbed SKS and go out there and it
felt like like have you seen the ghost
in the darkness yeah it reminded me of
because it's like all this tall brush
and you just hear like you know the dogs
barking over here and so I'm like oh man
the Bears over here and then over here
you hear up oh crap
it's over here you know like and then
all of a sudden Ragman I'm we're kind of
in this tall brush better but I'd like
it was like well I got my camera so I
handed the gun to this dude and he's
just like I figured he knew what he's
doing a bad choice but I got my camera
he got the gun and then again we're
looking at where the dogs barking and
the bear like pops up right here and
stands up it's like hmm and dude just
took off running with the camera I had
recently had a knee surgeries it's like
I wasn't running out of there so I just
like stood there and duck back in the
brush and then dude comes back like a
full you know almost a minute later I
was just like there's like my knees are
shaking I was like dude you got a gun
don't run and just as I said that it
stood up again and he's like dude you
sound like Vietnam so you guys want to
be eating it
well we they were all of thank you
people and they ate the heart but they
don't need oh they have like a whole
ritual when they shoot a bear it's like
the because they're so worming up there
you can eat them in like a serious
situation but what they would lightly
like cut the head off and put the eyes
under a rock because they didn't want
the like spirit to see where where who
got it so they like enemies they put the
other parts of it in the river so that
it floats down to like a different
village so that the bear thinks those
are the people like but in general
because there's so so much trichinosis
and stuff they don't eat the brown bear
up there but although you can if you
boil the heck out of it yeah we're just
cook it over 160 right yes I don't know
yeah yeah my father
we got a trichinosis how did he Steve
Rinella oh yeah you saw the whole crew
got it and they even got t-shirts isn't
that mild trichinosis crew isn't it
did they get rid of it I imagine it just
goes away but it's always in your body
so if somebody ate him someday they
gnosis how interesting
yeah he said it felt like his muscles
like you could feel the little the
little parasite worms yeah your muscle
so it's everything is in pain yeah and
then eventually just goes away yeah
[ __ ] worms just living in your body
it's creepy man because when you I
haven't experienced this but I know that
some people who eat bear have cut open
the bear and seeing the worms literally
crawling underneath the skin oh yeah
yeah no you could see them even on the
bear that bear yeah yeah you'd see them
in there they're like yeah it's pretty
gnarly so you guys ate the heart only
that's is just the heart to me I'm a
little bit of a waste but yeah that's it
I was kind of doing When in Rome you
know yeah that's one of those things
right like if you insult them and the
[ __ ] are you doing
of things they were doing so and you're
out there making bear barbecue how big
was the bear there's a brown bear big
old brown bear I mean it wasn't an old
one it was probably uh it's hard to say
but it was a full-grown foot and yeah
somewhere I put a picture of the hide
but anyway here yeah he's a big bear I
don't I don't actually know what I did
with that video which is very sad but no
guys you ate the moose you ate the heart
of the bear and how do they do that they
just sliced that up yeah I just sliced
it up fried it up and then yeah there's
a lot of bear stories out there you're
constantly I can only imagine constantly
interacting with them when you're always
in the woods like that
well unhappy people the guy was talking
about losing his favorite hunting dog
yeah yeah that happens that the way they
do dogs over there they think you're
interesting cuz they have a different
dog for every type of animal so if you
got like a dog that's really good at
treating birds and you got a dog that's
good at going after bears and you got a
dog is good at Sabol you know like you
just keep raising dogs until you get one
that likes to go after what you need it
to go where are they getting their dogs
from it's just like this a Venki breed
of dog I don't know just random looks
like just their like either white mutts
yeah looking things are not very big but
they're not small is average fire coyote
sized dogs and they uh yeah usually
white or red or spotted and what do they
feed them just mush like this like oat
mush stuff they buy in the Ville it's
not very good food but then the the dogs
like and try to fend for themselves and
stuff get your minds and things it's
like a they're like not an enviable the
dog seemed pretty happy but they also
like you know you'll go out and super
cold weather and this dog will have
melted a big hole in the snow and it
could snowed on top of it and you're
like pops up sleep outside
they're tough dogs yeah yeah and they're
eating just mush yeah they just eating
mush and like certain scraps and stuff
but yeah I'm not an enviable diet they
have they're usually kind of thin but
yeah they don't know any better they
like it they seem happy running around
free like that
incredible em yeah yeah super cool
[Applause]